ポンッ
はぁっ
はぁはぁんっ
[音楽]
ん
me
突然ですが私から皆さんに質問があります
この中で何か募金をしたことがあるという方
手を上げていただけますか
ほとんどの皆さんがありがとうございます
何かこう募金をした時に私もそうなんですけれども自分の心が満たされるようななんか
こう自分の気持ちが嫌って輝くようなそんな気分になる人も多いと思います
それはきっとほとんどの皆さんが常に誰かの役に立ちたいと思いながら毎日生活して
いるからだと思います
それでは質問を変えます
目の前に困っている人がいてその人への支援が大好きでワクワクするという方
手を上げていただけますか
ちょっとさっきより少なくなっていますありがとうございます
きっと今私の口から私怨っていう言葉が出た途端に一気にハードルが上がってしまう
ようなちょっと身構えてしまうようなそんな気分になった方もいらっしゃるんじゃない
でしょうか
実際昔私もそうだったんです
支援
それは
強い人とか力がある人つまり
ものすごく特別な人が弱い人を助けてあげること
それが死んだと思っていました
でもそんなシーンに対するイメージがあるとき
すっかり変わる経験をしました
そして今私がイメージしている支援の形はこれです
お互いに補い合うような形
それは決して一方的なものではありません
ん
それは
清い人が弱い人を一方的に助けてあげることではなく
お互いつまり支援する側にとっても足りない物を補えるっていうことです
これだけを今日覚えて帰っていただきたいと思います
今から10年前の話をします
私は大学一年生のときでした
社会的に弱い立場にある様々な人々について学ぶ授業をきっかけに
タイ台湾中国フィリピン
4カ国の日本に住んでいるアジア g のお母さん達と出会うきっかけがありました
その時お母さんたちは自分の強みをテーマに話し合いはしていたんですけれども
日本に住んでいてすごく困っている話
悩み事の話や自分に自信がない
そんな話ばっかりでもちろん横行自分から自分の得意なことはこれで知って言えるよう
な雰囲気ではありませんでした
そんなお母さんたちの姿を見たときに
すでにお母さんたちは数十年長い方だと二十数年間日本で暮らしています
なのに
なんでこんなお母さんたちは自信がないのか
と何かがお母さんたちの自信を張ってるんじゃないか
そんな風に思いました
だから私はその時のお母さんたちと一人ずつじっくり話をすることにしました
すると分かったことがありました
お母さんたちが異国の地9日本で生活する中で抱えている問題っていうのは
すごく複合的なもので私たち日本人が普通に生活している中では気が付かないような
問題を多く抱えていました
例えば子育ての問題
お母さんは日本語をうまくしゃべることができません
でも日本で産んだ自分の子供は日本で成長していくのでパール瞬間からお母さんよりも
日本語が上手になります
すると子どもは例えば小学校で何か嫌なことがあったとき
何か宿題を出された時お母さんに相談しようとするんですけれどもそれに対して
お母さんはうまく日本語で伝えることができません
ると
子どもはだんだんとお母さんのことをバカにしてしまいます
そしてコミュニケーションが取れなくなってしまう
次に
夫婦間の力関係の問題
言葉の壁や試合の少なさからお母さんたちは家に引きこもりがちになってしまいます
お母さんたちにとって家っていうのは本当に唯一
落ち着ける場所であるのにその居場所である家の中でもだんだんと旦那さんとの力関係
が大きくなってしまって
旦那がおかあさんに暴力を振るうようになってしまう
そんな問題
そして最後に
働く場所がないという問題
お母さんたちは片言でコミュニケーションを取れるだけの日本語を話すことができます
そういう方はたくさんいらっしゃいますでもじゃあ日本語の読んだり書いたり感じとか
ですね
ができる方がいるかと言うとすごく少ないです
すると日本では働ける場所ですとか触手っていうのがすごく限られたものになって
しまいます
今話した三つの問題は本当に一部の問題だと思っています
そんな話をお母さんたちから聞いている時に思ったこと
それは
今まで力があったのに異国の地の日本に来た途端に自分ひとりの力でできないことが
あまりにも多すぎて
そうするともちろん自信を失ってしまうし
本当に最終的には自分の価値って何なんだろう
で思うようになると思います
世界ではさまざまな社会問題があふれています
でもお母さんたちの抱えている問題
それは光が当たっていないと思いました
光が当たっていないから彼女たちの問題に目が向かない
そして目が合わない
そんな社会で私は暮らしたくないそう思いました
だからお母さんたちが輝ける瞬間ですとかお母さん達に光を向けること
コレってどうやったらできるんだろう
ずっとそれを考えました
いうとお母さんたちが輝ける習慣っていうのはすぐに見つかりました
お母さんたちはミーティングで集まるときに自分の国の料理
母国料理をおうちで作ってタッパにいて
私たち食べて欲しくてよく持ってきてくれました
私は当時大学1年 c でエスニック料理を食べるのがその時は本当に初めてだったん
ですけれども
すごく驚きました
甘かったり辛かったりしっぱ買ったり言葉で表現できないような刺激的な味なんです
けど
とにかく本当に美味しいんです
お母さんたちは自分の国の料理の話をしているときにすごい誇らしそうにしています
普段だったら自分の日本語が伝わるかなぁという気持ちが先に来てしまってなかなか
こう日本語しゃべってくれないこともあるんですけれども自分の国の料理を説明する時
はすごく積極的に話をしてくれます
それはなんでかっていうと自分の作った料理のことを伝えたいから
自分の生まれ育った国のことを伝えたいから
すごく楽しそうに話してくれました
そんな姿を見たときに
お母さんたちが生まれ育った国だからこそ文化だからこそ
環境だからこそできるこの目の前にある凄く美味しい料理
これが
必ずお母さんたちの自信を取り戻せる大きなきっかけになるんじゃないかと確信しまし
た
当時私は大学生だったので大学の中で1日限りのお母さんたちの料理を販売するような
屋台のイベントを企画することにしました
ここでとある台湾人のお母さんの話をしたいと思います
彼女の名前は u さん
勇さんは日本で数十年間暮らしていますが自分一人でどこかに出かけるとなると自分の
家からどうぞ
夜ご飯とか食材ごはんの食材を買いに行く市場までの徒歩10分圏内
電車ももちろん乗れませんし
主年間日本でその徒歩10分圏内の往復しかしていない
それを聞いたとき
私は単純にものすごく驚きました
そんな優さんなんですけれども
この屋台のイベントで勇者の得意な台湾の焼きビーフンを作ってもらうことにしました
ただ優さんは本当に自信がなかったです
自信がなかった理由はまさか屋台なのでお金を払って日本人が自分の国の料理を食べて
くれるはずがない
今まで友達とか数人の子にしか
ビーフを振る舞ったことがないからなん十色も作ることはできない
やったことがないしできないしそんなわけないし
本当にないないだらけの u さんでした
集客は100人以上を見込んでいたそのや大イベントなんですけれども
なんどもー勇者にセット効果されて作ってもらったビーフンの数
それは
30食
朝から夜までのイベントなのですぐに売り切れるに決まってるんですけれども
ユーザーにとっては全部が初めてで初めて作るなん十色のビーフは本当に大きな
チャレンジだったと思います
そして実際にイベントが始まって
開始30分で優さんのビーフンはもちろん売り切れてしまいました
私たちもそうだなーとは思っていたんですけれどもそんな体験をした u さん
その優さんが言った言葉は
あんだけ作れないと言ってたのに
なんでもっと作らなかったローっていう逆ギレ等
次は100食作るっていう70食以上大きくなってるんですけど
100食作るっていう大きな地震でした
そんなユーザーの姿を見たときにこれは優さんだけじゃなくて他のお母さん達もだった
んですけれども本当にたった1回のこの屋台のイベントをきっかけに
お母さんたちはお客さんによって自分の強みを認識して大きな自信を手に入れた
そして企画した私たち学生はできるかすごく不安だったんですけれども実際お客さんが
たくさん来てくださってそれって自分たちがこんなイベントをするっていう伝える力
いいいいお客さんが集まってくれた
だから自信がついた
そんな経験をしました
支援で聞くと
なんか大変そうで自分ごとにはできないかもしれません
でも初めに質問させていただいたように
募金をした時とか例えば米社で誰かに席を譲った時に
自分の気持ちがキラッとちょっとだけでも輝いた
そんな気持ちの延長線上にお互いを補い合える
支援の形があると思っています
互いに足りないところを補い会う過程で気がつく
自分の強み
弱みそして何よりも自分の勝ち
それらに気がつくと
支援する側
される側
そういった関係を超えてお互いに力を引き出しや嘔吐します
そしてそれは
お互いにワクワクできるんです
ただ目の前の問題が解決するだけじゃありません
そんなお互いがワクワクできること
これを私はこう呼んでいます
エンパワーメント
そんなエンパワーメントのきっかけをもっとたくさん
もっと継続的にたくさん作るためにはどうしたらいいか
そう考えて私はその時に生涯かけてそういう場所を作ろうと心に決めました
そして今私は
神戸の南京町で頭アジアン食堂バルサラというちっちゃなアジアン食堂営んでいます
8カ国中7名のスタッフと一緒に作り上げているお店です
大学時代に屋台のイベントを企画してからお互いに補い合う支援を続けた結果
このお店ではたくさんのエンパワーメントの電車が起こっています
当時ビーフは3次職しか作れない
そう言ってたの台湾人のお母さんは十数年後期比を経て今ではこの皿で
看板シフトして毎日頑張ってくれています
そしてなんと不来年度には優さんの夢でもある
台湾料理の専門店を出店することも決まりました
この絵はサラの入り口に書かれた壁画です
お店のコンセプトに共感してくれたフィリピン人アーティストの施主さんという方が
直接壁に書いてくれました
この会のテーマはエンパワーメントをフォールピーポーん
すべての人々がエンパワーメントされる世界
セシルさんがこの絵に込めていただいと思い
それは
国籍も関係なくて男性も女性もまた妊婦さんも子供も
それぞれがそれぞれの立場からお互いの価値を認め合い
そしてなによりも自分自身の価値を認めることができる世界
きてないないづくしだったゆうさん
今では
当時の自分と同じような境遇のお母さんたちを輝かせる側になりました
そんな姿を見て私自身も大きく勇気づけられてそして私も輝きたいと思いました
そんな風に
輝いている人を見て自分も輝きたいと思う
そんな輝きのレーサーを引きこを引き起こすことそれがお互いに補い合う支援の形だと
思っています
お互いに輝くことができるエンパワーメントの連鎖を今日この会場にいる皆様とも一緒
に起こせることを強く願っています
[拍手]